Hank: Good morning John, it's Monday!
Katherine and I are in the San Juan Islands
for our fifth...
year... anniversary.
C'mere.
Katherine: Y'wanna... bring my chair, or just
come over there?
Hank: You can bring my - you can bring your
chair.
We are on our fifth year anniversary vacation.
Katherine: Yes, we are.
H: It's been five years that we've been married.
K: Mm-hmm.
H: What do you think?
K: I could do it for another five at least.
H: So she's in for another five, folks.
K: At least five.
H: I don't think that's how marriage works.
K: Come - come - come ask me again.
H: In another five years?
K: Yeah.
H: Where are we?
K: Ah, we are in Washington State.
H: Yep.
K: On San Juan Island.
H: This is -
K: Why are you petting me?
H: I love you.
It's an nice - it's a nice place for staying,
though, right?
K: Do it again.
H: Ooooaaaaahhhh, hahahaha.
I wanna show everybody something.
K: He's gone.
Oh, this is - in - this is indicative of how
nice the place we're staying is.
H: This is how - this - this is how you know
how, how, how nice a place is.
K: This is the toilet bowl brush.
H: If it were to talk, what would it sound
like?
K: Oh, I don't know.
I don't know what a toilet brush says, there
-
H: Helloooooooo!
I clean the loo!
K: Euaaahhh!
What's wrong with you?
Nooooo!
H: When we got married, what did you think
of me?
Has it changed?
K: No.
H: No?
K: I mean, we were - we had, we had, we'd
dated for a long time before we got married,
so, y'know, I had a pretty formed opinion
of you.
H: What do you think about nerdfighteria?
K: Appreciative...
H: You also want me to have more time... in
my life.
K: I love hanging out with you; that's like,
my favorite thing to do.
H: Aw.
So you're jealous of them.
K: A little bit jealous.
Sometimes.
H: Are you enjoying Hankgames?
K: Yeah, it's really fun.
And I love going back and watching them, and
seeing, like -
H: Oh! we had fun!
K: - the stupid jokes we made.
I never was, like, a person who played video
games by myself.
Even when I was growing up, when we had like
NES...
H: Yeah.
K: ...it was most fun when my friends would
come over and we would play Battletoads.
H: It's a social thing, yeah.
It's now to the point where there are games
when you can play multiplayer that you can't
play local multiplayer, you have to play it
online.
K: Yeah that's sad.
H: That's sad to me.
Even watching other people, like even watching
Melissa play Ocarina of Time.
K: Or Pikmin.
H: Or Pikmin, yeah!
K: What a good world.
I like that little world.
H: Mmhm.
Them happy little guys dying for you.
K: Yeah, they just decide that they really
like you and follow you around.
"Throw me at a thing!"
They just needed a leader.
(fog horn blares outside)
K: Oh!
Both: A ferry!
H: What do you think about ferries?
K: I don't believe.
H: You don't believe in ferries?
Ohhhh!
She doesn't believe in fairies!
What about slugs?
K: Oh, I like slugs.
I didn't know that I liked slugs.
H: We, yeah.
K: I hate like the tiny little garden slugs.
H: Slimy.
K: Lemon will lay down in the grass and she'll
stand up and there'll be like nine slugs on
her legs.
H: But in Washington, there's like these HUGE...
I'll put video of them over this.
K: Well, we didn't even see like the big banana
slugs.
H: Banana slugs.
And you were like stroking it.
K: They're so cool!
H: Yeah, and it was like changing shape.
K: Yeah!
H: It was like a Transformer.
K: It's got these different body shapes - parts.
Yeah.
H: Different colors and they're really big
and I, I touched its eye and its eye was like
BWANG!
It was really cool.
K: So I really enjoyed meeting the slugs in
Washington.
H: Yeah, and then our Washington friends were
like, "Yeah, they're slugs.
They're gross.
You step on them and it's gross."
So it's beautiful here, so we're going to
go for a hike now.
K: Yeah!
Both: Yaaaay!
H: Thanks for being married to me.
K: Thank you for being married to me.
I like it.
H: John, we'll see you on Wednesday.